welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness's latest trailer
dump confirmed massive names from marvel
lore in this film the illuminati
actually called that name which we were
not sure they were gonna do since
apparently it sets off youtube's
conspiracy alarm also what looks like
the faces of the living tribunal so i'm
gonna break down all the new details in
how they really reframe what we thought
this movie was gonna be let's go
strange it's time
in 10 days
nothing can prepare you
for the truth
everything you've ever known led you to
this moment
stephen strange the illuminati will see
you now
so we open on the close-up of strange's
broken watch that we have seen before
the watch that christine palmer gave him
in the 2016 film and will play an
important role in this story as a key
that unlocks the portal hatch in that
one shot leading to the book of vishanti
also new promotional stills were
released showing strange repairing that
broken watch and wearing it at
christine's wedding also in that shot
the program that strange holds reveals
that her husband to be is named charles
and you can actually see charles
following christine outside in a past
trailer then a quick shot of strange
rushing to tackle america chavez as she
appears to be in the process of being
drained of her energy as she floats
before a series of star portals and as
strange does this embers drift off his
cloak of levitation showing us this was
the moment it is scorched which likely
leads to the other shots we've seen in
past trailers of the burn scars on that
cloak so i assume it is the scarlet
witch who is draining america in this
moment maybe stealing america's innate
ability to kick star portals through
dimensions as the scarlet witch
continues her warpath through realities
in search for her sons i like how
america's life force takes the form of
this whitish blue energy reminding us of
the visuals vague of the hardness
draining the other witches of the coven
in one division episode viii america
does look a bit emaciated as those other
witches did when agatha was done with
them and this could also be how defender
strange later looks so emaciated and
zombified in this film i also like how
the borders of america's star portals
are just a little brittle and icy like
this process is draining the heat energy
from a system and reducing it to these
cold crystalline shards which might then
lead to strange in america tumbling
through the multiverse as it shatters
around them and we see the beginning of
this as they fall past the in 10 days
title the structures of kamartage
zipping past them just like they did for
strange when the ancient one first slung
shot him on his first trip then a new
overhead shot of wanda using her chaos
magic on this stone platform in the
shape of say it with me kids hexagon
just as wand as hex did in one division
and surrounding her on this hexagon are
six circles each with their own
geometric design in the middle all of
this evoking the design on the page of
the dark holes which also appears on the
back wall of the temple also notice how
around this hexagon the surfaces appear
to freeze over some of them puffing up
dust like this could be within that
frozen mountain top location which
crumbles as wanda casts her spell a
close-up zooms into her eyeball as it
did for that other shot in the february
trailer but this time it shows the bony
demonic figures that attack defender
strange and other shots here lit from
beneath with the red glow now i'm not
sure if one is deploying these upon
strange or just witnessing this happen
then a new shot of american defender
strange sliding down and then leaping
from the collapsing structures of this
utopian parallel if that is what this is
toward that book of ashanti platform we
can also see light streaming in through
a circular stained glass structure
giving this whole setting a heavenly
sacred feel then a new shot of strange a
new patch sewn into his cloak with
variant christine palmer seen before in
the illuminati lab and at the side as he
goes through the hatch they're both now
in this darker sinister sanctum room and
the space is filled with lit candles
there's also something on the ground
before his feet almost like an open book
maybe the book of ashanti he may be
conducting a seance to cast a productive
counterspell to wanda's witchcraft and
at the end of this country he'll have to
slam it all back in the book as we saw
in the february trailer and then here we
go the ultron sentries shove strange
into the courtroom where mordo supreme
says strange the illuminati will see you
now yes it is confirmed this seven
seven-person panel is the mcu's
illuminati which in marvel comics is a
summit of superhero leaders kind of like
the un world security council that in
the comics consists of professor x reed
richards doctor strange tony stark namor
and black bolt they form themselves to
protect earth from cosmic invaders but
here in the films they seem to be a
multiversal governing body like the
council of ricks and rick and morty we
know that one member of this panel will
be patrick stewart professor x from the
x-men film universe actually a screen x
promo showed even more of the back of
his head we should tell him the truth
we will see who else is on this lineup
next week days away but i have some
thoughts about how this multiversal
judicial body could fit within the full
mcu pantheon of law and order at the end
of this video now we do a lot of early
morning shoots here at new rockstars and
i cannot afford to not be at my best
just because i had a delicious ipa or
two or three or all of it the night
before well z-biotics pre-alcohol
probiotic is a genetically engineered
probiotic you drink before drinking
alcohol to avoid that rough next morning
and get back to living your life phd
scientists invented it because they know
the real problem is not dehydration it's
a toxic byproduct of alcohol in
xebiotics pre-alcohol probiotic is the
only product that breaks that down just
one zebiotix before you start drinking
is all you need to enjoy your night and
still look forward to tomorrow drink
zebiotics before you drink alcohol and
it works throughout the night breaking
down the toxic alcohol byproduct that
makes you feel awful the next day it's
real science that works so whether you
want your tomorrow to be a productive
one or uh you know just another fun one
or a relaxing one don't let a few drinks
the night before ruin it drink a bottle
of zebiotics pre alcohol probiotic
before you start drinking combine that
with your healthy and responsible
drinking habits and when tomorrow rolls
around you'll be ready to make the most
of it so get 15 off your first order of
xebiotix pre-alcohol probiotic by
clicking the link in the description box
and use my code new rockstars at
checkout go to zbionics.com new
rockstars and get 15 off your first
order and in case this wasn't clear this
product and uh the product it helps you
with should only be consumed if you're
old enough drink responsibly play by the
rules don't be a jerk still drink a lot
of water and give this a shot but then
we get this new dizzying shot of
defender's strange's fight with the
swarming demons on that mountaintop from
the perspective of one of those demons
as strange swats him away actually as he
does so you can see he is wearing his
sling-ringing device on his index middle
finger and we still haven't seen sparkly
sling ring portals opened in any of this
footage so maybe these devices are
defunct lash out of this promo show
strange in the sinister sanctum locked
in a duel as his golden bands get
overtaken by purple sorcery i'm sorry to
keep doing this but purple was the color
of the dark magic used by agatha notably
as she reversed the other witch's blue
spells and turned them purple is strange
fighting agatha here that'd be awesome
but doubtful i mean this is probably
just the color of sinister strange's
magic which might be pulled from the
same dark dimensional source that agatha
pulls from but we gotta talk about the
other major cameo in the social media
promos one features the ancient ones
lined from the 2016 film and shows
american wong atop a mountain as america
blasts them into another dimensional
space with multiple cloaked heads with
glowing eyes i'm counting three sets but
there may be a fourth set of blowing
eyes behind them and then another 10
days promo shows the same shot from a
different angle folks this is almost
certainly the living tribunal the
ultimate cosmic judicial authority of
marvel lore a colossal body depicted
with a three-faced cloaked head the
three faces representing equity
necessity and revenge the living
tribunal famously acquitted thanos of
his crimes in the infinity gauntlet
storyline and we actually saw a statue
of the living tribunal's head in the
void in loki episode 5 and michael
waldron the showrunner of loki wrote
this multiverse of madness script now
remember mordo unveiled the staff of the
living tribunal in the 2016 film and the
infinity war screenwriters revealed that
they initially drafted doctor strange in
thanos wizard duel to feature a thanos
trial in front of the living tribunal
now it's interesting to note here that
the multiple faces are separated from
each other as opposed to attached to the
same head one face exposed the other two
cloaked but this might be the form the
living tribunal takes on a fourth
dimensional plane all three faces of
equity necessity and revenge surrounding
its defendants in equal judgment looking
at their souls from multiple angles like
when the living tribunal presents itself
in only one universe we see it in a
three-dimensional axis but in a
multiverse of multiple dimensions
stacked on top of each other this is how
it looks now with mid-level judicial
entities in the mcu like the illuminati
but also ahmet anubis and the iniad and
moon knight as well as irishm the judge
and eternals and then the tva and loki
it just makes sense for this film to
introduce the chief justice final
authority for all these lower courts the
ultimate judge that strange wanda loki
or cersei everyone could try to appeal
too and maybe the reason we saw the
statue's head severed in loki could have
been a clue pointing to the living
tribunal being another target of gore
the god butcher the villain currently
going from cosmic entity to cosmic
entity slaughtering them in thor love
and thunder i only bring this up because
the one other time we've seen a giant
severed head in the mcu was nowhere and
according to marvel comics lore that
celestial was beheaded by the same
weapon that gore now carries i mean
whatever ends up happening folks the
living tribunal either being killed or
indisposed somehow maybe overruled in
some way could be part of the
multiversal crisis that all of these
characters now find themselves in and
the reason that nexus beings like wanda
can wreak their havoc across all these
realities now a reminder to check out
our moon knight inspired two with moon
god shirt over at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstar subscribe to
the rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you